on va
bonjour
alors antoine lehoux et moi même nous
allons réaliser devant vos yeux
une expérience qui consiste à verser la
même quantité de lentilles dans deux
entonnoir identique
le tout à tan tan dung quat là alors la
seule différence entre nos deux méthodes
c'est que antoine applique un contrôle
sur les lentilles il les oblige à ne pas
se précipiter au fond du béchère alors
que moi je les laisse donner libre cours
à leur volonté individuelle de se
précipiter au fond et des chaires tué
près 1 2 3 alors vous pouvez voir
normalement que les lentilles des
d'antoine cool de manière continue et
voilà il a déjà fini alors que moi
mêlant qui se sont toutes précipité
comme un seul homme dans l'entonnoir
merci antoine et bien il ya même des
moments où ça s'arrête
carrément de couler donc ceci est
destiné à d'abord vous montrer une
expérience de physique à luzenac est
jolie et ensuite vous faire réfléchir
sur la notion d'optimum individuelles et
de petits même collectif alors je me
situe ce sont des grands mots optimum
alors optimum individuel ça veut dire
que chacun cherche la maximisation de
son bien être optimum collectif ça veut
dire que tous les individus applique une
règle qui leur permet de maximiser leur
bien-être collectif
alors là c'est magnifique c'est
complètement bloquée alors que j'en ai
encore voyez que si je laisse cou
j'avais peur que ça se passe pas très
bien mais à vrai dire c'est même lui qui
vient alors nous avons donc un optimum
collectif et un optimum individuel
chaque lentilles que j'ai appliqué mois
elle a cherché à aller le plus vite
possible alors que celle d'antoine on
obéit à une consigne
alors les réalités j'avais prévu des
transparents et même une [ __ ]
c'était très pensée et donc avec cela je
peux vous montrer qu'il y avait un
bouchon au dessus de ces lentilles alors
l'idée je vais illustrer le principe de
petits mômes collectif et l'optimum
individuel sur le cas des voitures mais
on peut lui illustré dans bien d'autres
situations
oui parce que moi je suis prof de
transport dans cette école et c'est pour
ça que je m'intéresse aux lentilles
alors
évidemment ça va de soi donc nous avons
un bouchon à droite et pas de bouchon à
gauche alors les voitures elles ont des
conducteurs les conducteurs ils peuvent
choisir d'appliquer en optimum
individuel ou un optimum collectif
lebron l'optimum individuel ça va être
le comportement de l'usager qui va
chercher systématiquement être sur la
voie la plus rapide qui va faire
beaucoup de changements de voie et on
c'est nous qui observant le trafic que
les gens je m'envoie perturbe le trafic
donc si vous passez votre temps à
changer de voie vous allez générer des
ralentissements pour les autres par
contre si vous restez bien sagement sur
votre voix si vous appliquez les
consignes les limitations de vitesse les
les carrefours à feux qui sont rouges ou
verts vous allez être un participant de
l'optimum collectif vous allez accepter
une diminution de votre bien être
temporaire de manière à ce que tout le
monde y gagne en global alors il ya des
moyens qui sont utilisés par les
gestionnaires de trafic
encore un gros mot je m'excuse pour
appliquer l'optimum collectif pour faire
en sorte que vous soyez convaincus par
la règle non tu as parlé pablos erwin
tout à l'heure vous appliquez vous
adhérez à une règle qui vous est imposée
pour satisfaire à l'optimum collectif
par exemple le cas le plus simple
alors oui pardon je reviendrai dessus
après excusez moi le cas le plus simple
de gestionnaires de trafic c'est celui
qui met un carrefour à feux sur un
réseau de routes
là ils appliquent une il annonce une
consigne aux usagers et leur disent et
rouge ne passait pas sévère vous pouvez
y aller alors que et donc ils imposent
cette comportement il impose en tout cas
il demande aux usagers d'adhérer à ce
comportement
pour satisfaire le petit môme collectif
alors dans la
donc je pense que maintenant vous avez
bien compris ah oui sauf que je vous ai
pas dit ce que c'était que le
gestionnaire le trafic ou le
gestionnaire d'infrastructure c'est
celui qui est payé par la mairie ou par
l'état pour assurer le bien-être
collectif pour édicter des règles qui
vont être appliqués par tous alors entre
maintenant et 1000 2084 il va se passer
quelque chose de relativement important
c'est l'apparition des véhicules
autonomes les véhicules autonomes
ce sont des véhicules dans lesquels vous
n'avez pas besoin de conduire dans la
voiture vous avez quatre roues un moteur
jusque là tout va bien et vous avez des
capteurs des rallyes d'art des radars
qui vous permette qui permettent au
véhicule de connaître la distance entre
ce véhicule est le véhicule devant le
véhicule derrière les véhicules sur les
côtés vous avez en permanence une
géolocalisation par gps et vous avez
surtout un ordinateur de bord très
puissant qui permet à chaque instant de
choisir la vitesse la voix
l'accélération qui vont permettre de
rouler en toute sécurité
alors du point de vue de la consommation
il ya des avantages par exemple cette
voiture elle est tellement sûr parce
qu'en fait le conducteur est génial
génère la plupart des accidents de la
route tandis qu'elle est responsable
dans 90% des cas
donc avec un ordinateur surpuissant et
qui connaît tous et qui est omniscient
il ya besoin d'avoir des voitures qui
soit moins lourde puisque vous allez le
choc n'aura pas lieu donc vous n'avez
pas besoin d'une grosse carrosserie qui
va absorber le choc
donc ça ça permet dé diminution de la
consommation mais est-ce que ça a que
des avantages ce véhicule auto alors il
faut savoir que le véhicule autonome y
en a trois sortes
il ya le robot auquel on a rajouté trois
roues et une méthode de calcul sur les
données ça c'est la navette navia qui à
confluences actuellement vous pouvez
utiliser donc c'est la voiture autonome
du roboticiens vous avez la voiture
autonome du constructeur automobile
donc renault toyota etc ont des voitures
auxquelles ils rajoutent
un ordinateur et des capteurs et puis
vous avez la voiture qui est hubert sans
chauffeur ou vous avez quelqu'un qui a
une connaissance de la gestion des
données et qui va rajouter quatre roues
et des capteurs à ce système de manière
à avoir un véhicule autonome vous voyez
que vous avez trois sortes différentes
de véhicules autonomes et que donc le
véhicule autonome c'est quelque chose
qui interagit dans le pardon dans lequel
beaucoup de choses interagissent de
l'informatique de la robotique de la
physique et de la mécanique
donc tu c'est typiquement un problème de
sciences de l'ingénieur et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que il faut pas
prendre le véhicule d'un homme comme un
isolat il faut prendre le véhicule
autonome dans son interaction avec
l'ensemble de la ville et ensemble des
aux usagers de la voie le système du
véhicule autonome comment on va le gérer
comment va lui demander de se comporter
pour nous il ya deux solutions la
première solution c'est lui demander de
se comporter de manière égoïste
donc on va posséder notre véhicule
autonome est très fier de ce véhicule
autonome le matin on va partir de chez
nous dans une voiture on va monter dans
la voiture
elle va nous conduire à notre travail on
va la renvoyer chez nous pour qu'elles
se garent gratuitement parce que le
parking en centre-ville c'est cher elle
va revenir chez nous tout seul pendant
ce temps là nous on va travailler le
soir on va lui demander de revenir et on
va repartir à la maison dans notre
voiture deux fois plus de déplacements
première solution la solution égoïste on
va dire
deuxième solution la solution où on
confie à une un centime un instant
supérieur un big brother le soin
d'assurer tous nos déplacements
donc on va demander avec mon smartphone
des courses de transports collectifs ou
de voitures individuelles qui nous
seront loués pendant la temps déterminé
et donc on va utiliser ses voitures pour
faire tous les déplacements dont on a
besoin
donc imaginez la société qui met à notre
disposition ses véhicules elle sait que
vous travaillez vous habitez
si vous faites vos courses elle sait où
habite votre amant et elle peut vous
proposer quand l'idole fait des
promotions sur les couches culottes de
vous emmener chez lidl donc ça c'est un
peu big brother donc vous avez cette
solution là et puis le véhicule
individuel
et puis il ya une troisième solution qui
est une solution de volonté des usagers
des transports des déplacements de
sacrifier une partie de leur autonomie
pour qu' il y ait une gestion collective
optimale du trafic qui permettent à tout
le monde d'échanger des informations
localement et de parvenir à un optimum
entre les voitures et donc entre les
voitures
mais attention il n'y a pas que des
voitures dans la vie entre les voitures
les vélos les trottinettes les les
personnes qui transportent des
poussettes les personnes en fauteuil etc
etc donc d'avoir une gestion collective
locale qui vise à obtenir un optimum
individuelle et donc à faire circuler
les lentilles plus vite
alors vous voyez que là on a une
interaction de plans de disciplines
scientifiques entre elles la robotique
l'informatique l'automatique un peu
d'économies un peu de psychologie et
beaucoup de mathématiques et beaucoup de
physique et tous à toutes ces sciences
elle elle concourt tout entre elles à
améliorer la société et à éclairer les
citoyens sur les solutions techniques et
technologiques est aussi humaine qui
vont permettre de faire en sorte que la
société aille mieux et donc c'est pour
ça qu'en tant que chercheuse sur ce
sujet je suis folle des sciences
appliquées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]